und jetzt kommen wir zu einem thema der
werden sie bestimmt ganz böse auf mich
sein ich weiß ich werde hier in der
runde dafür wenige punkte gewinnen aber
ich muss es dennoch ansprechen und zwar
geht es um die sanktionen und mein thema
heute abend ist noch stärkere sanktionen
werden uns den wohlstand kosten die
sanktionen sind schon jetzt eine große
gefahr für unseren wohlstand unternehmen
drosseln die produktion weil sie sich
nicht mehr leisten können diese
aufrechtzuerhalten
viele menschen müssen erneut den
kurzarbeit weil aufträge fehlen und die
energie um bezahlbar geworden ist die
wirtschaft ist der motor dieses landes
unseres wohlstandes und dementsprechend
das ultimative gegenmittel gegen
gesellschaftliche spaltung der ost west
konflikt wird noch viele jahre
vermutlich jahrzehnte
und wenn ich es nicht hoffe andauern für
diese auseinandersetzung brauchen wir
eine starke wirtschaft und wir brauchen
wohlstand nur so können wir die völker
in russland und china von der demokratie
überzeugen ich finde alle bislang und
das ist mir sehr wichtig die ukraine
krieg beschlossenen sanktionen richtig
jede einzelne die bislang beschlossen
wurde ist richtig wir müssen uns zur
wehr setzen und sanktionen sind ein
probates mittel und die bisherigen
sanktionen werden wir alle gemeinsam
aushalten für die ukraine und für die
freiheit auch wenn sie die wirtschaft so
sehr treffen aber jetzt reicht es es
stört mich ungemein dass politiker und
journalisten immer höhere sanktionen
fordern ja am liebsten sofort das öl und
gas embargo ohne über die folgen für
unser land nachzudenken
es sind genau die berufsgruppen die von
den sanktionen nicht betroffen sein
werden die regierenden politiker haben
wir nehmen am main versprochen schaden
vom deutschen volk abzuhalten ich weiß
dass es kein leichtes unterfangen ist
die ukraine in ihrem freiheitskampf zu
unterstützen und gleichzeitig das eigene
land vor allzugroßen wirtschaftlichen
schäden zu bewahren aber wir müssen es
versuchen einen energie im wago kann
meiner meinung nach nicht die lösung
sein ich bin davon überzeugt noch
härtere sanktionen sind nicht der
richtige weg die bisherigen haben ihre
wirkung noch lange nicht entfaltet und
putins krieg wird dadurch nicht
schneller enden aber wir werden
verlieren wären amerikas öl industrie
profitiert und jetzt traue ich mich kaum
hennig anzuschauen reagieren
ich glaube dass gerade die deutschen sie
haben das in der hand was
sie gegenüber einbrüchen auch benutzen
könnten und sollten und dass diese
abhängigkeit die entstanden ist in den
letzten jahren jahrzehnten der beiden
koalitionen vorher und jetzt müsste man
auch diesen hebel genau diesen hebel bis
zu ende auch ins spiel bringen dann wenn
man die sanktionen sind hart da haben
sie recht in der tat sie entfalten ihre
wirkung zwar nicht kurzfristig das ist
auch wahr sie können nicht gleichzeitig
und sofort das verhalten von herrn putin
verändern aber wenn man zum beispiel
sich gedanken machen über ein moratorium
also ein monat lang beschließt die haben
bei der regierung kein gas kein öl und
keine kohle zu beziehen als signal das
heißt man könnte einen monat überleben
ja das ist das wäre auch ein signal und
das ist vielleicht auch ein
zwischenschritt zu schauen vielleicht
wird das schon diese diesen effekt haben
wo herr putin schneller sich entscheidet
auf den verhandlungstisch oder zum
verhandlungstisch zurückzukehren und
wirklich über den frieden zu reden und
nicht nur vorzutäuschen also ja ich
glaube auch ich erkenne in unserer
sanktionspolitik und sozusagen den
pfeilen im balco hin oder her auch diese
deutschen lust am immer alles
hundertprozentig machen natürlich kann
man so etwas in betracht ziehen und
damit eine eskalationsstufe die erste
eskalationsstufe scharf stellen ich
glaube aber anders als nena auch dass
man wenn man sich in einer so harten
auseinandersetzung einem krieg dafür
entschieden hat aus guten gründen nicht
militärisch in den einzutreten sondern
als waffe die sanktion gewählt hat dann
muss man auch nach laden können wenn
sozusagen die erste salve nicht reicht
deswegen fürchte ich dass wer da a sagt
muss auch in der lage sein b sagen zu
können weil er sonst nicht ernst
genommen wird und ich finde auch bei der
sogenannten jetzt und technisch
gesprochen bepreisung der sanktionen
lässt es sich schnell bemessen was
kostet es wenn wir einen barcoo
verhängen was hat das für auswirkungen
auf die wirtschaft wir müssen aber auch
mit einberechnen was heißt es für die
volkswirtschaft in deutschland und
europa wenn dieser krieg fortgesetzt
wird und deswegen finde ich an der
stelle wir machen es uns da oft zu
leicht und greifen so schnell nach den
preis barren dingen wir müssen in diese
kosten abwägung aber auch einstellen
welche folgen hat die fortsetzung des
krieger ich finde wir machen es uns viel
zu leicht und das ist ja industrie also
das öl und energie embargo ist wirklich
leicht es ist auch leicht zuvor hat das
hat jemand in der pauschalität dem land
sondern wir haben uns ja bewusst
sozusagen für ein abgestuftes system
jetzt erstmal entschieden und ich finde
das ist immer noch eine balance gewesen
bei den jetzt gewählten sanktionen und
auch bei den diskussionen die wir
fortsetzen aber es werden ja immer
härtere sanktionen gefordert das würde
doch während immer ein herz aller kriege
geführt von wladimir putin gegen die eu
beide entlassen lassen lassen sie uns
einmal heran vorbei und wenn sie es mir
erklären können dann wäre ich in die
kamera sagen es tut mir leid nicht
fordere es jetzt auch erklären sie mir
bitte wie soll der krieg beendet werden
wenn wir dieses öl und energie in bar
druck machen weil der punkt ist der da
wir werden es nicht mehr bekommen aber
china wird beziehen dadurch dass die
preise steigen kann russland
kompensieren ich glaube nicht dass wir
da mit putin aufhalten können ich sehe
nur wirtschaftlichen schaden hier werden
geschwächt aber ich sehe nicht dass
dieser krieg endet und dementsprechend
deswegen bin ich dagegen ja es wird
keine maßnahme dieser welt geben die den
krieg isoliert betrachtet beendet
sondern es geht um ein bündel und es
geht darum wie stark die
entschlossenheit ist die wir als
westliche welt gegen wladimir putin l
das noch alles muss nein heißt das nicht
moralismus es geht es geht im krieg im
übrigen aus meiner sicht auch nicht nur
um moralismus und es geht auch nicht nur
um pragmatismus sondern es geht darum
dass wir für unsere werte auch ernsthaft
einstehen und wir müssen deswegen schon
auch bereit sein kollateralschäden auch
bei uns selbst zu akzeptieren und wir
müssen deren legen roland schaden haben
ja wir haben wir haben
volkswirtschaftlich haben wir alle den
schaden davon und im übrigen muss für
uns auch klar sein dass es um das
maßnahmenbündel geht und wenn wir jetzt
schon putin zeigen in der aktuellen
situation ist uns dann die eigene
volkswirtschaft und nur weitere
einschränkungen ist uns näher als der
stoppen des krieges dann ist es das
falsche signal wir müssen das
ausbalancieren und müssen im übrigen
deswegen sagen wir sind wirtschaftlich
entschlossen russland noch weiter zu
isolieren wir sind militärisch
entschlossen gegen zu halten und
brauchen deswegen ein klares bündel
sozusagen auch an entschlossenheit das
heißt nicht null und eins das heißt
nicht sofort wirtschaftsembargo das
heißt nicht in den konflikt militärisch
eingreifen aber wir sollten jetzt nicht
zurückschrecken vor putin und müssen da
auch klare stärke zeigen wir geben ein
mal zu pannen ronzheimer live nach kiew
was er zu unserer diskussion sagt ich
glaube ich werde ganz schön was
abbekommen das mach ich aber gerne hin
ich bin ehrlich gesagt relativ müde das
immer wieder zu dir zu erklären warum
das wichtig ist aber ich akzeptiere
natürlich deine meinung und auch die von
allen teilnehmern und natürlich ist es
so dass wenn man gerade in kiew sitzt
das sehr sehr anders betrachtet mein
punkt ist wenn wir es nicht schaffen
putin in die schranken zu weisen wenn
wir es nicht schaffen hier die freiheit
der ukraine zu verteidigen mit den
ukrainern dann geht europa verloren ich
bin da sehr auf der seite von herrn
moravec ski dem polnischen
regierungschef für das so ähnlich gesagt
hat gestern und wenn wir es nicht mit
waffen erledigen wollen was wir nicht
tun wollen wir wollen nicht teil dieses
krieges sein wir wollen auch nicht
wirklich mit großen ansporn der ukraine
mit waffenlieferungen helfen wir tun
dass so ein bisschen halbherzig
überlassen das aber den amerikanern wir
wollen auch nicht dafür sorgen dass eine
flugverbotszone gibt na ja dann müssen
wir uns irgendwann mal entscheiden und
die sanktion diese bislang gibt das sind
die die wladimir putin ohnehin
eingepreist hat er hatte vielleicht
nicht eingepreist dass das militär so
marode und schlecht ist und dass alle so
viel angst haben dass keiner ihm die
wirklichen zustand dieses militärs
berichtet hat aber die sanktion die
bislang beschlossen sind die hat er alle
eingepreist und ich glaube über die muss
man dringend
hinweggehen mit dem ziel das blatt die
mut ihn noch stärker in die enge
getrieben wird und dass am ende ist eine
möglichkeit gibt dass er vielleicht
gestürzt wird oder aber dass sein
engstes umfeld ihn dazu bringt
dieser mörderischen politik zu machen